first time playing against him in the
NBA
obviously touched on earlier great
players over there and he's one of them
um you know he's definitely a guy you
got to know where he is at all times and
uh it's it's a cool first uh full circle
moment I guess you could call it um you
know going to his Camp however many
years ago it was and uh you know now
being in in the league with him and
playing and competing and you know
that's what it's all about I want to go
out there and compete with these dudes
and they want to do the same so uh it's
great you know they're they're up one
one0 on us and um you know we just got
to continue to get better and um for
when we see him down the line